agriculture Minnesota Prosper had the
opportunity to see first hand the
shipment of small Machinery brought in
under the second phase of the
enhancement of the efficiency of
production distribution supply chain in
the fruits and vegetable sector project
also known as the seven Corps project
the shipment which includes tillers and
cultivators aims to reduce Farmer's
Reliance on labor while increasing
efficiency and optimizing land use
ultimately improving Farmers quality of
life ambassador of the Republic of China
Taiwan to Saint Lucia has Excellency
Peter chaiyan Chen explains that using
modern agricultural Machinery is
critical to improving a Farm's
Effectiveness and efficiency he says his
government remains committed to
assisting St Lucia's agriculture sector
in transitioning to more advanced
farming methods Taiwan and solution have
long-term agricultural cooperation and
our agriculture project always
successful one and in Iowa is the idea
of Minister Prosper to apply
technician technical old technology yeah
into agriculture so we decided to impose
some of the machines that we use in
Taiwan and try to introduce this machine
to the local farmers and help local
farmers to be more successful in their
production and also with all these
machine
also these ideas come from Minister
Prosper I try to attract more youth into
agriculture business so I believe this
will be a very good initiative and I'm
looking forward to see the good outcome
Minister for agriculture Fisheries food
security and rural development honorable
Alfred Prosper says with the numerous
challenges that the sector faces the
introduction of small Machinery as part
of efforts to make the agriculture
sector more attractive to the younger
population he emphasizes the importance
of adapting to farm mechanization as one
of the innovations that could be
critical to Future food security because
it allows for the production of more
crops at a lower cost Farmers have been
operating more seasonal than year round
I want to know that our farmers can
produce from January to December every
year and not have to suffer the
consequences of weather conditions in in
the dry season when production is always
low in order for us to meet our food
security needs the strategy must
Encompass new technologies and this is a
simple and easy form of bringing this
technology into the sector and more
importantly I am convinced mechanization
will attract more young persons into the
sector I've always said young persons
are not
soaking on using the crew bar and using
the garden for can using cutlasses but
they are getting to understanding value
of small implements like this to ensure
that they can reduce production costs
and make a greater profit from the
sector the next phase of the initiative
will see a public showcase to introduce
Farmers to the logistics of accessing
the Machinery as well as its cost from
the communications unit of the Ministry
of Agriculture I am anesia Antoine
reporting